。
同学们好啊。
今天咱加一节课。
讲一个最近网上很流行的话题，好吧。
凡尔赛。
最近晚上很流行，是吧？
才猜啥意思啊？
我理解其实就是。
比较优雅的在不经意间哎装了个逼是吧？我是这么理解啊。
但其实这个东西啊，凡尔赛这个现象。
在咱们这个领域啊。
其实是重灾区。
你不觉得吗？
在在文艺界文艺圈，文艺小青年里面，创作圈很是很容易就凡尔赛起来了，气氛很快就凡尔赛起来了。大家如果一起聊天的话。
但是咱们的课啊。
是个实战课。
我呢。
在大部分时候是尽力在追求，用最通俗、最好理解的方式，让大家学会知识，学会实战，学会写剧本。所以呢我其实很少去讲术语，或者是讲一些很晦涩的底层理论。
这就导致咱们的同学呢在这个领域先天有点吃亏呀。
先天有点吃亏，然后也有同学跟我反映说老师可以适当的讲一些。
那些玩意儿。
让我们在凡尔赛这个领域呢也有点武器。
我一想也是。
对吧。
因为啥呢？因为。
装逼这个事儿吧。
在社会生活中。
在社交中。
其实是刚需。
有时候完全不装逼。
确实也不行。
对吧我我也有体会啊，我同学们我生活里面啊需要装逼的场景其实比较少。
因为我已经过了那个阶段了，对吧？我不需要让人家知道我懂。
我这时候反而我用通俗的语言给大家讲明白，反而是最大的凡尔赛，对吧？人家觉得哇，这个老师牛逼是吧？平易近人，但是我也有吃亏的时候。
前段时间啊。
在咱们的学习班里。
因为咱们早期的那些班级啊，我经常喜欢在里面跟一些老学员聊聊天。
在群里聊天，然后就有些同学呢。
看我冒泡了。
加我好友。
我心情好的时候呢，哎我就通过通过了这些好友。
然后就有个同学。
跟我聊天，很激动说啊，老师竟然通过我的好友了。
是吧。
那个那个老师你好啊，我是你的学生，我从你这学了很多知识。
然后就说啊啊你好你好，这个这个这个好好学就行了，对吧？能学到就就挺好。
然后他就跟我说，哇，老师你怎么回复我呢？
你怎么搭理我了？
老师是不是你也不是很忙？
我还以为你是腕儿呢。
看来你也没啥事儿干是吧？
然后这个同学这几句话也打不好。
一下给我整懵了，你知道吗？
吓得我赶紧把他拉黑了。
我怕他不拿我当腕，你知道吗？
对用宋丹丹的话说，也太不拿人当腕了。
吓他们赶紧把他拉黑了，你知道吧？保持我的神秘。
嗯。
这只是开个玩笑啊。
跟同学们没有必要凡尔赛。
但是在社会生活中啊。
确实是。
有用得到的时候只能这么说吧。比如说你说。
你去跟朋友吃个饭。
对吧大家坐一块聊天啊，你不是学编剧的吗？啊跟你聊，或者是哎你去相亲，跟人姑娘第一次见面，吃个饭啥的。
这个大家肯定都问啊，你喜欢什么呀，那对吧？
反正每个人都喜欢啊，我喜欢旅游，我喜欢什么，都说自己喜欢旅游。我其实他妈从来不出去，为什么喜欢说旅游，对吧？就也是凡尔赛嘛啊，我喜欢电影，都喜欢说自己喜欢文艺的嘛，喜欢电影。然后万一人人家女孩万一也懂一点电影跟你聊起来，你咋整，你好歹也是个学编剧的呀。
聊不过人家。
那不完了吗？
所以这节课呢咱们加一节课拿出点时间呢讲一讲这个这种情况。我不是教你们凡尔赛，我是教你们如何应对。
这种场景在这种场景。
出现的时候，如何应对如何游刃有余的。
处理是吧？
毕竟你说咱好歹是搞创作的，不能在这种场景下吃了亏吧。
所以在这里我们先强调一下啊，在讲这些东西之前，先强调一下我的立场。
在凡尔赛这件事情上。
咱们。
没事儿不惹事儿。
有事儿不怕事儿行不行？
这节课咱们讲一讲如何应对这个凡尔赛。首先说。
在凡尔赛的场景，最容易出现的情况有哪几种？我觉得有三种。
第一种。
其人。
好，理解吧。
用咱们东北话说，就是我等着我摇人啊，我给你摇个人，对吧？然后双方就开始聊人，提人，提这种著名导演一般是这边说我喜欢詹姆斯卡梅隆，这边说我喜欢盖里奇是吧？我喜欢呃，这个乌迪艾勒，我喜欢希嘘哥克。
是吧我喜欢库布立克。
我喜欢费得尼。
就开始提人，但是你要谁先要说出来一个啊，我喜欢。
冯小刚基本就败下阵来了是吧？就输了。
为啥呢？这个东西吧，冯小刚。
你说冯小刚的水平比那些导演低吗？其实不一定不一定。
但是呢。
提冯小刚你就输了，你就说不过人家了。
那在这种提人的情况下，我们怎么应对？
首先我们要了解一下提人的规律。
敌人的规律。
一般他们爱提什么样的人呢？
两种。
呃，两个特点提的人小众。
远方。
就是越小众越好，越远方越好。
越远方越好。
为啥呢？
但也不是无限小众和远方啊，他们还是要让你听到过的。
让打开知道，所以这就造就了你心虚来了。你跟他们聊这时候，你就心虚了。你就会以觉得哇这个导演我是听过对吧？我是听过这个导演，但是呢他拍的这些片子，他拍过哪些片子呢？我就好像不太了解。
我好像也说不到说不了下句了，对吧？
首先不要慌不要慌。
他们为啥提小众提远方呢？就是故意要这样嘛，故意要触及对方的盲区嘛。
首先我们先分分析一下这种心理状态啊，为什么会有这种情况，在文艺取向上，为什么会出现往小众往远方走的这么一个？你看啊，其实比如说。
咱们的宁浩导演冯小刚导演。
他的片子你也很喜欢，但是你在这种场景下，你为什么不就不敢提呢？我曾经在无数次啊在课上做过这个实验，我就问同学们，我说同学们，你们最喜欢的导演是什么？我就挨个问他们挨个站起来回答，你知道吧？啊个个神采飞扬，各说各种那个那个国外的导演，我跟你说连。
别说国内导演了，就算是好莱坞导演，都没有人说四皮胳膊这种因为太。
太大众了。
他们也不说。
那这种情况是为什么呢？我们先在要知道这种心理状态，我跟大家讲一下啊，就是人啊是一种社会动物。
人在社会里面啊。
追求两样东西，就社会生活啊，追求俩东西，一个叫安全。
一个叫存在，就说我们的很多行为啊，往往是在这两种追求的支配下做出的。
啥意思啊？
用大白话说啥叫安全？
就是我要跟你一样。
我跟你一样的时候，我我觉得安全。
枪打出鸵鸟啊，对吧？我跟大家一样呀。
那存在呢？
就是相反的，就是我要跟你不一样。
对吧我要有我的个性，哎，我跟你们不一样。
就是这两种追求啊。
永远是同时存在的，它是在角力。
他有一个平衡，有个balence。
我们说。
在安全感。
相对较低的时候，你对存在感的需求也相对较低。在安全感高的时候，你对存在存在感的追求也相对高，它是一个平衡，一个balance。
我们就说你看啊在过去这种不安全的时代。
就大家普遍安全感偏低的时候，也没有人追求存在感。
啥叫存在感？我跟你不一样？那个时候就所有人都一样，穿的衣服一样，颜色一样，款式一样，发型一样，对吧？
他们鞋也都一样，然后行为都一样，说的话也都一样。
没有人追求存在感，就是因为他的安全感低。
但是现在这个开放的时代呢。
大家的安全感普遍比较高。
所以呢在追求存在感上。
要求就越来越高了，要追求大型的存在感。你看以前我说所有人穿衣服都一样，现在谁有人愿意跟你穿一样的衣服，撞衫是一种尴尬呀，对吧？撞衫不可怕，谁丑谁尴尬嘛？
他连撞衫都不愿意了，不愿意跟你穿一样的衣服。
所以说其实就是在安全感。
得到了极大满足的情况下，大家对存在感的追求很高。
但是存在感的追求也不能突破安全底线。所以呢就造就了一种现象，我给这种现象有一个定义叫什么呢？叫我跟你不一样，但是我跟远方的人一样。
我跟远方的人一样，确保了我有安全的底线。但是在我的身边，我有巨大的存在感。
这就是。
小众远方，这就是文艺青年的文艺追求，这也是时尚的原理。
你发没发现时尚不就是这么个玩意儿吗？哎。
你不觉得很奇怪吗？就是我们穿什么衣服，觉得什么衣服流行，今年流行这种对吧？就裤子，今年流行小脚啊，过几年又流行这个这个喇叭，过几年流喇叭又吐了，又流行小脚，到底是在受什么东西支配呢？
对吧其实就是在受我跟远方的人一样支配。
你穿一件衣服，你不想跟身边的人一样。但是你觉得我这件衣服啊在上个周纽约时装周，哎上面有人穿过，在米兰时装周有人穿过米兰街头很多人都穿这个明星都穿这个，你就是在追求跟远方的人一样，就造就了一种所谓的时尚。但其实那边的人呢说不定在那看着东方或东方那帮人。
穿着哦拎着一个哦那叫什么大口袋对吧？啊，我们也造一个吧啊，穿着一身大花袄，我们也弄一件吧，就是大家都在追求跟远方的人一样。
这也就是时尚。所以你看啊你明白了这个原理之后啊。
其实你不用害怕。
他们提人呢就愿意照着小众，照着远方提。
所以造就了你啊，对那些人啊不是那么的了解。
这都很正常，你不用慌，因为正常情况下，他们的电影其实我们都看过。
那些大师的电影其实我们都看过。
只是我们没有去对位他是哪个导演拍的，因为没有那个必要。
对吧。
所以在。
在凡尔赛场景下，第一个最容易出现的情况就是有人提人。
在这种情况下。
咱们怎么应对呢？
我推荐咱们的同学。
你你就照着这个方向使劲，你知道这个思路了吗？
你去找那种。
俄国导演，我跟你说，俄国导演啊曾经在电影史上是做出过巨大的贡献的那开创了很多呃流派，开创了很多技术技法，也有很多大师。但是他们的片子呢足够小众，足够远方。
你去背几个这样的名字，我是背不下来啊，我因为不带烦。哎，这个这个同学们在弹幕上啊自己查到的，在打在弹幕上，供其他同学也可以学习一下，对吧？比如说我我比较喜欢。
前苏额导演。
嗯，尤里克。
妥斯别克斯斯基是吧？就名字当然瞎掰拿。
你马上成为全场之王。
而且你如果还能说出他的片子，以及他开创了什么样的。
影像。
技法。
那你就牛逼了，对吧？所以碰到有人提人，你就拿。
前苏联前俄国导演。
治他。
绝对给他治了背服了，而且他不服还不行。当时那个时代，那那那那那确实是俄国导演确实是制霸世界的呀。那那那个斯坦尼斯拉夫斯基不也是。
那那个那所有人都星爷那翻的那本书，演员自我修养，对吧？那说明他们曾经确实很强大的。
明白了吧？有人跟你提人，你不要顺着他们说，你提一个俄国的。
然后在凡尔赛场景下，提尔只是第一招。还有呢很多种情况下大家喜欢。
就开始直接提个片了。
几个片儿来。
比如说啊说啊你喜欢什么电影啊啊，我喜欢这个踩火车啊吧？文艺青年都喜欢啊，我喜欢教父，这个是影史一直这个排第一，对吧？排第一的电影。然后在题片这个环节呢。
大家凡尔赛起来之后呢。
有些同学心又虚了，咱们的同学，有些同学心又虚了，虚啥呢？
他们在那聊教父啊。
我没觉得教父好看呢。
是吧。
我看教父睡着了好几回呀。
看了好几遍都没看完呀，三个多钟头一步啊。
然后你不就心慌了吗？你就觉得哎呀是不是我。
没有艺术品味呀，我这看教父都睡着了，我羞愧啊。
是吧。
出现这种情况，你又心虚了。
这里我也跟大家说一下啊。
不要许。
看教父也好。
踩火车也罢。
睡着了。
也没事儿。
没事儿，因为他们确实。
有点沉闷。
对于。
你们来说。
题片儿。
你要片子。
有一个很重要的理念，就是你脱离时代去看一个作品。
你其实是永远是不准确的。
比如说教父。
你说教父牛逼不牛逼呀？
当然牛逼。
他在他那个时代绝对的牛逼。
绝对的牛逼。
但是脱离时代再去看呢。
也确实沉闷。
为啥？
教父牛逼是牛逼在。
他是70年代的电影，他在那个年代第一次把黑社会。
像人一样去刻画他刻画黑社会的家庭。
他没有说刻画这些黑社会，他们是坏人，他刻画这个人，他是一个父亲。
他是一个儿子。
她是一个丈夫。
他是一个哥哥。
他刻画的是黑社会。
全面的人格。
这在现在来看。
非常的正常。
但是在那个年代。
他却是具有开创精神的。
他是具有开创精神的。因为在那之前啊。
角色往往大家追求的是极致，追求的是脸谱化，追求的是极端的设定，好就是好坏就是坏，对吧？
这是当时的审美，当时的追求并不是说当时落后啊。
他是每个时代有每个时代的。
特点。
但是呢时代在发展，审美也在更迭。
就是人民群众对于审美的追求和故事创作方式的发展，它永远是互相推进的。
而那些牛逼的经典的能载入史册的影片，他往往就是踩对了那个脉搏。
就是人民群众正好呼唤。
有有点感觉哎呀廉谱画的人物是不是可以变一变呢？哎，你踩准了。
那他就把你奉为划时代的经典了，你也确实是。
时事造英雄嘛。
真的是这样。
不是谁谁的时代，是时代中的谁谁，就是这个意思。
十四招英雄。
这种片子他往往就是踩对了时代的脉搏，大家又踩过头了，踩的完全就听不懂了。若干年以后，大家才觉得哇这个片子不错，然后呢。
也有守旧的。
比如说。
比如说有声电影刚刚出来的时候，就电影以前是默片。
呃，大家有印象了吧？末片时代大家就啊就用动作来演。
然后配那种字幕，说现在演到哪了，配点字幕，信息量就很小。然后突然出现。
录音设备了录音设备的话，然后就演员就可以说台词了。
演员就可以说台词了。
这就是时代发展，观众很想听声音，想听台词，对吧？既然有留声机了，有录音设备了，我们想听演员说台词啊，有声音的故事更动人呀。
但是你看当时墨篇时代最大的巨星就是卓别林啊，卓别林带头开始反对抵制有声电影。
对吧他就说啊，演员怎么可以说台词呢？
如果说台词的话，就影响我们表演的纯粹性了呀，对吧？但咱这个时代咱当然觉得不可理解。但咱当时就是这样，他觉得说台词的演员那还叫演员吗？那简直是耍赖嘛，我们是就用形体表演的呀。
他就抵制。
最后当然他也妥协了，对吧？因为时代发展是不可逆的。所以说你看啊。
每一次变革的时候，第一个踩对的踩对点儿的片子，再加上当然他各方面也要拍的好啊，然后又踩对了点，他往往就是。
成为了经典影片，所以你不能脱离时代去。
聊一个电影。
就像教父一样，他是70年代的片子，距今50年了，对吧？
你你看不懂，或者是你看的时候觉得就那么回事，对吧？就那么回事，很正常。
正常。
再比如说啊我课上经常讲的牛逼的片子，阳光小美女。
阳光小美女，我在课上反复讲，我说这个片子牛逼呀，非常好看，对吧？非常好看。
但是我相信也有很多年轻的同学会觉得嗯是挺热闹的，哎，好看挺好看。但是传世经典哎。
达不到不至于吧，就会有这种想法，对吧？这也很正常这也很正常。因为这个片子啊描绘的是70年代。
末70年代末80年代初的一个时代，描述的是那个时代的故事。你脱离这个时代，你也看不懂这个片子它牛逼在牛逼在哪。
阳光小美女这个片子讲的是啥？讲的是一个胖胖的乡下小女孩。
相貌平平，相貌平平，这个词儿相貌平平。
想去参加选美。
想去参加选美啊，他想当阳光小美女这个选美比赛去参加这个选美比赛。
显然是一个。
对吧看起来有点愚蠢的。
失望的一个想法。
然后呢，因为这次很想去，所以一家人。
就。
陪他去。
这一家人都有谁？有爷爷。
爸爸妈妈。
然后一个自刚自杀的。
舅舅。
然后一个不说话的哥哥，5个人陪着小美女去参加这个。
选美比赛。
最后的结果是什么呢？
选美比赛显然。
肯定是选不上的，也不可能选上。但是。
一家人在送。
小女孩参加比赛的过程中全部得到了。
救赎。
得到了救赎。
我们看一下这5个人啊，你看爷爷。
爷爷是越战老兵。
越战老兵。
越战。
在美国历史上。
那肯定是。
影响了一代人，影响了两代人。可以说。
让很多人有伤痕。
然后那个爷爷显然。
并没有走出战场。
他吸毒，他最后就是欧弟死掉的嘛，对吧？吸毒过量死在路上。
这是一代人的伤痛。
越战。
然后呢。
妈妈是什么人？
从妈妈的行为。
抽烟，包括他那个车，那个黄色的那个大众那个车。
他妈妈显然是。
美国垮掉的那一代的代表人物嬉皮士那一代的那个那个口号啥？要做爱，不要作战。
对吧他们追求性解放，追求。
毒品啊、烂椒啊。
显然是垮掉的一代的代表人物。
这是他妈妈。
然后他爸爸是干嘛的？
爸爸是一个成功学讲师，是吧？成功分九步是吧？是吧？有钱人的五大要素就讲这种的这个东西啊，在美国曾经一度。
风靡全国，为啥？因为人都很赚不到钱，人都很空虚，就追求这种虚妄的东西，就成功学的东西，精神鸦片呀，那就是就他家人有吸真毒的，还有吸精神毒品的，就他爸他爸是精纯毒品的毒贩子。
贩卖成功学，一个穷光蛋在贩卖成功学多么的讽刺，对吧？
但是曾经那识风靡。
西方。
前几年也风靡咱们。
也也在咱这儿也曾经也很有市场，很多人在那听懂鼓掌，是是这么说，还听懂掌声，忘了，反正各种成功学对吧？你怎么长得咱就不说这些了，是吧？就是很多人在那贩卖成功学，他爸爸是这样的一个人。
然后。
他舅舅。
刚刚自杀，从医院抢救回来，所以呢需要监护人看着，不能离开，所以才会跟着一块上路。
为什么自杀？
是弯的啊铜性对吧？他他他舅舅是。
是弯的，在那个时代，显然不被受贿。
所接受。
在那个时代显然不被。
认可，而且他还是大学教授，肯定会受到各方面的压力。
这也是时代的悲痛呀，对吧？你看现在大家都很容易接受很友好的一个环境。但那个时代显然不是。
既然不是。
又是代表美国社会的一大上头。
最后他那个哥哥那个不说话的哥哥。
号称要考空军，考不上不说话，对吧？最后发现自己是个色盲，根本就没有办法去考飞行员。
就是哥哥代表什么呢？
这个稍微隐晦一点，很多同学可能体会不到。
从他家里挂的海报。
家里画着泥彩。
挂着那个还挂着一只鹰啊，这个这个。
哥哥是个小纳粹呀。
是个小纳粹。
这个种族主义者，种族歧视。
种族歧视显然是美国社会的一大伤痛嘛。所以你看这家里呃当然了，咱们强调一下啊。
你踩。
本人。
是不是一个纳粹主义者？
学术上基本上是否定的。
这个跟咱没有关系，咱们因为不是哲学课，咱也不去讨论这个问题。
但是呢我们只是就现象而说，他挂着尼彩的海报。
一定程度上。
影片是想表达。
这小子呢？
再往那条路上走，好吧，咱们这么去理解，我没有诋毁尼踩的意思啊。
就说这5个人啊。
他家里这5个大人。
代表了美国社会的。
五打伤痛。
看起来都人无人六了，但其实无种无大伤痛，然后反而是这个笨笨的胖胖的。
追求想当选美小姐的。
小小女孩。
才是最正能量的。
他才是在追求美国梦。
他才是正能量，他做的事情才是最真实的。
是这么个意思。所以你看从这个角度，你再去看这个片子，它并不是一个单纯的喜剧片。
他其实是很沉重的。
也是划时代的，所以这个片子才会得那么多的大奖。
就是因为他。
是有它的时代的价值的。所以你看啊在提片的时候，人家给你提个片儿。
提教父，提阳光小美女。
你觉得啊就那么回事，没啥意思，你也不要慌不要慌。
是因为你不是那个时代的。
但是真要聊呢，你就可以通过时结合时代。
去研究一下这个骗子。
好吧，就是有人跟你提片的时候，你也知道是怎么回事儿。
然后在凡而在场景下。
其人齐片都经常见。
第三种呢。
如果提了，那就是比较有技术含量的探讨了。啥呢？
体场戏。
这个就比较具体了，这个就比较见见功夫了。他给你直接提一场戏。哎，我们聊一聊那场戏，你觉得怎么样？我靠，这个我就提这个。
是吧没有两下子，你就应付不了。我们说提人提片儿的话，我们基本上都能糊弄过去。
要是提一场具体的戏。
咋整？
打败。
我觉得作为咱们的同学啊，咱们也不能慌啊，咱们也必须能拿下聊场戏，我也教大家怎么去聊。
比如说啊当然我们是从编剧的角度啊，不是会不是说从镜头呀，从光影的角度去聊。咱们从咱们的。
本行的角度，从剧本的角度，从故事的角度去聊。
聊具体的戏，具体某场戏也有的聊从故事角度。
也有得了。
也没问题，也可以轻松应对。
比如说我给大家找一场戏。
霸王别姬里面的一场戏，霸王别姬啊是咱们国家的电影里面。
少有的可以在世界上。
不管是东方还是西方人，都认可他在世界影史。
排进前五前十的这么一个水准。
霸王别姬。
真的是相当。
完美啊相当完美级别的一个电影。
我们从霸王别姬里面找一场戏，找一场比较有代表性的戏。
比如。
那场。
就是承叠一。
加入细班以后。
他师傅让他被私凡。
啊，那个我本是女娇娥那一场戏，他师傅让他被思凡。
他老是背错。
老是背错，老也记不住，挨打也记不住。最后呢。
他师师哥就是段小楼，男主角段小楼拿烟袋锅子，他又一次背错，给师傅惹了祸的时候，他师哥急了，拿烟袋锅子。
捅他的嘴捅的他满嘴流血，然后他嘴角挂着血，眼里含着泪，终于把这段私凡。
背对了。
就是这么一场戏。
这场戏我也能背下来，我给大家背一背啊。
小尼姑年方28。
正青春被师傅削去了头发。
我本是女娇娥。
又不是男儿郎。
为何妖记黄涛身穿直多？
见人家夫妻们撒落。
一对对着锦穿罗。
不由得心急似火。
奴把袈裟扯破。
是吧。
就这么一段啊，哎，大家看一下这几场戏啊，看一下江相乎力把山兮气盖世不离兮骓不是骓不是兮可奈何，玉兮玉兮奈若何。
小尼姑年放28，郑庆春被师傅削去了头发。
夏文呢我我本是男儿郎我本是男儿郎。
你本事女江娥你我本事我本事你本事什么呀啊，我本事男儿了？
我。
我本事哪儿了。
师傅说的信你全忘了，下次再忘就往死了打你，我让你错，我让你错看错。
小子长点记性。
这个。
你要是给打死了。
这底下有啥大字？
就给你了。
嫂子。
过两天就要给祖师爷上香了，你就想你自己是个女的。
可别再背错了。
。
真段也还不错。
有点坤腔的底儿没有啊，呃，学在两处嗯。
男怕叶问，女怕思凡，就来段思凡吧。
小尼顾年方28。
正青春被师父削去了头发，我本是男儿郎，又不是女骄傲。
为何？
那爷那也实在是对不住您的，实在是对不住孩孩子平常改是这样的谁叫你回来，我叫你哭叫你哭叫你哭哭。
张鬼张鬼。
撤错呀，睛叫你错叫你错叫你错叫你错车呀睛错。
嘿哩哈哩。
。
是。
小尼姑年方28，正青春被师父削去了头发，我本是女娇娥，又不是男儿郎，为何妖系黄涛身穿直多，见人家夫妻们洒落，一对队浊颈穿罗，不由人心急似火，奴把袈裟。
可错。
好啊，就这几场戏。
如果我们说人家开始提茶戏了。
这场戏从剧本的角度，从故事的角度大家聊一聊吧，大家凡尔赛一下吧。
那你咋聊？
首先说这场戏当然是非常好的一场戏啊，非常棒的一场戏非常棒。
它是一个很重要的节点，是承蝶一这个角色的。
一次重大的转变和成长。这个我们当然都知道。但是你说转变和成长这词，这这种词儿就是太怯了呀，是吧？我们还是得整点硬词，我教大家一些硬词，好吧，比如说聊这场戏。
第一种思路。
我们可以从。
关键词啊。
关键词给大家提几个关键词。
英雄。
从英雄的角度去聊，因为啊所有故事中的主角本质上都是英雄。
都是一个个的英雄。那凡人在成为英雄的过程中啊。
是有一些关键性的节点。
政治仪式。
在这里。
这场戏针对这场戏。
这是什么节点呢？
这叫。
我们的主角。
在于天赋。
争夺世界控制权的过程中。
彻底失败。
接受了来自复权的摧毁。
很生色是吧？很生色是吧？
这个理论来自于哪呢？
来自于一本书叫千面英雄。
还没有。
也就是说你可以从坎贝尔的。
思维体系里面。
说这个事儿关键词就是英雄。首先主角就是英雄，对吧？
这场戏很显然是。
与复权争夺控制权。
与天赋争夺控制权，为啥？
因为。
谁让他背这俩词儿？
师傅啊。
一日为师，终身为父啊。
然后他背不好，谁拿烟袋锅子捅他的嘴？
哥哥呀诗哥呀。
对吧长兄如父呀，我们知道小豆子就是程蝶一啊，他现在还叫小豆子，小豆子没有爸爸呀。
他妈妈也把他抛弃了，他妈妈是是是是青楼的对吧？然后生下他以后，把他送到戏班，切了他的六侄儿，把他送到戏班，把他扔在这儿。蒋文丽那个角色，我最喜欢的华语名演员蒋文丽那个角色。
把小豆子送到。
戏班。
然后就走了。
等于他妈妈把他抛弃了，对吧？他妈妈把他抛弃了，然后。
当天晚上睡觉。
师兄弟儿们嘲笑他是。
妓女的孩子不要这样的。
他做了一件什么事儿？
他把他妈妈留给他的唯一一件棉大衣，就是他妈妈留给他的唯一的东西，一件棉大衣烧了。
宁愿冷，宁愿光着屁股。
那件衣服烧了。
这就是英雄在成长中的第一步与母亲的保护彻底绝裂。
也就是他已经做了做完第一步了，他与母亲已经彻底决裂了。
然后又与复权争夺世界控制权，然后彻底被摧毁。
师傅和师哥都是来自父亲父权的摧毁。
摧毁了他。
他背错什么？他老是说，我本是男儿郎，又不是女娇鹅。
实际上的词是什么呢？司法里面的词儿应该是我本是女娇娥，又不是男儿郎。
他被他们摧毁了，被他们赋权摧毁了，让你承认。
你是个女交鹅，所以这从英雄的角度，关键词英雄，你就可以知道这是一个反英雄的主角。
因为英雄的主角应该是在与父权的争夺中获胜的。
但是他失败了，他坠入了反英雄的套路。
千面英雄这本书。
是这个理由坎贝尔我介绍一下啊，坎贝尔大家不要小看它。
乍一看好像不怎么样啊，就是说他好像挺没溜的。因为坎贝尔是个什么学家啊？
坎贝尔是一个神话比较学家，就就国外的有很多稀奇古怪的专业，你知道吧？你说你研究神话，就神话学就可以，它叫神话比较学。
是吧。
我就是说就国外的大学有很多稀奇古怪的专业，真的特别古怪的专业都有我在想有没有。
比如说美食比较学对吧？人家问你啊，你研究美食比较的对吧？研究美食我们理解那你会做菜吗？研究美食比较那川菜啊。
香菜辣。
鲁才咸好，答辩成功，毕业了去。
就这这种专业也太没溜了是吧？但是呢坎贝尔大家千万不要小看他坎贝尔是。
人类历史上最伟大的。
呃，作家之一绝对是之一精神导师之一，他是很多很多人的。
精神导师和精神支柱，包括我们的。
那个那个那个。
呃，斯耐德就写救猫咪这套书的斯耐德先生，他也是什么奥巴马呀、什么比尔盖茨呀。
泰森对吧？很多人的精神导师。
当然了，他不是咱这行的人啊，人家写这个那本书叫千面英雄，他写的就是神话比较学，就是比较世界各地的神话，找出里面的共同性，找出英雄的共同性，因为啥呢？
因为古代的神话。
各地有各自的神话，但是他发现有很多共通之处，他就把这个共通之处总结出来。
共通之度总结出来。
这就说明一个问题啊。
因为神话最早是人类传送的创造的梦想的。
神话是个梦呀。
那么共通性就说明什么呢？
我们拥有共同的梦。
英雄是众人的梦。
是众人的吗？
所以电影也是众人的梦。
他寻找的是我们共同的那些梦想。
所以坎贝尔的这套理论啊受到了很多。
编剧导演。
追捧大家去研究，确实很有用。
但是原书比较晦涩，因为他举的全是。
那些对对对，就是人家。
呃，人家的那些神话理论你你你你肯定觉得很晦涩。但是如果结合咱们国家的，比如说西游记、孙悟空哪的啊，你一看你就就比较容易看懂。比如说啊你说神话有些什么样的共同性。有很多共同，我随随便给大家讲一个。
就是凡是英雄人物啊。
父亲都不想。
或者说这个父亲啊不是不祥，他也有，但是你就会觉得不靠谱。
一般是什么拒人，对吧？
嗯。
龙。
天神是吧？
或者是还有一阵风的。
当然大部分就是没有。
像孙悟空这种石头蹦出来的，你根本不知道他是谁的咋。
这种情况就。
就很普遍，对吧？
很普遍。
不就符合咱们创作剧本里面，我讲男主角要有血统。
有血统，但是出生频反嘛。
对吧来自凡间，但是有血统，那不就是这样吗？你是。
你父亲不祥，但是啊是个牛逼人物把你扔在这儿。
把你扔在这儿。
这个就是古代神话的共通的地方。
但是你要去细研究，这是为啥啊？古代神话为啥有这种情况啊，其实就是来自早期。
母系社会的那种。
因为母系社会啊，女性是独立的。
他不是男人的附庸。
他呢。
自由择。
对吧它不是男人的私产，不是男人的生殖工具，它是自由择偶的。但是呢人呢因为开化比较早，知道这个近亲啊肯定是不能瞎瞎来的对吧？
不能瞎来，所以就有这个外婚制。然后在母系社会他，他外婚制怎么玩呢？就怎么外婚呢？一个氏族啊是不能繁殖嘛，那你怎么玩呢？就类似有一个。
公共区域，比如说附近的这几个族这几个村的人。
比如说每每月初一15。
到那个那片小树林里。
去集中。
搞这个交配活动，相当于比如说朝阳公园是吧？每每个礼拜天朝阳公园有一次交配活动，然后大家呢都去那儿去取经去取经。
你看啊我们还原一下这个场景。
假设你是那个时代的一个女性，适龄女性，你去了。
然后回来之后。
别人肯定问你了。
别人肯定问你呀。
你跟谁？
你很有可能就凡尔赛起来了。
你不一定照实说呀。
你如果赵实说啊，叫那隔壁村那吴老二。
哪个不来。
就那个瘸的。
啊，对，还有点凸，就那吴老2。
你自己也没面啊，对吧？虽然你确实是跟物老二，你转了半天，没找到合适的。哎呀，就他了就凑合吧，反正对吧？不能白来一趟呀。
但是你肯定不好意思这么说呀。
你这时候你就就开始凡尔赛，开始吹。
就说啊我跟那一个嗯。
1个11111个大个。
啊，长得老帅，一米八几大个。
他是哪村的没见有一米八几大个啊，可能不是不是那不是咱旁边这村的外外外外面村来的一大个。
啊就吹嘛。
然后其他人就开始觉得这妈这小娘们找了个大个啊，就开始你你那一米八几哦，一米83米啊，我那1.96米。
然后就开始吹，然后呢我那2.26米姚明是吧？他越吹越没边了啊，我那7.4米就开始出现巨人的传说。你看啊西方有很多。
说自己的父亲是北方的巨人，说是哪哪的巨人。
心里有点数吧，对吧？
就开始吹，最后那这个东西吹没边儿啊，你不可能吹到最后说啊，你那多高，我那个8848米，你他妈做成五狼瓦风啊了，是吧？
也不可能越吹越没边儿啊，就地上的吹完了就开始吹天上了啊，我那会飞，对吧？啊，我那是天上雷神，我那是太阳神，就开始成，我那是天上的真龙。你看龙的儿孩子也很多呀，龙的后代也很多呀。
就就就就就开始吹。所以你看这些英雄啊，他往往。
他就跟他妈合谋，得把自己的爹。
因为反正当时无没法考证嘛，你也不知道，所以他就吹。
再讲个小故事，咱们中国的你看。
我们说刘邦。
汉高祖刘邦他已经是完全的富权社会了。
但因为他是一个。
草民皇帝嘛，对吧？草民皇帝就出身很平凡，最后机缘巧合成了事儿。
他觉得自己这个心里有点虚嘛，毕竟不是贵族血统嘛，他就有点虚。
他也编了这么一个瞎话。
对吧他说他妈你看古咋记载的，我记不清了啊，他说他他也不是凡人。
他说他妈有一天。
吃饱饭。
出去溜达，去消化神儿。
说在一个。
湖边吧，大泽啊在湖边溜达溜达溜达呢就有点累了，就在湖边这么一躺，然后天降真龙，一条龙从天而降，一条蛟龙从天而降。
是从天而降还是从大泽里窜出来啊，咱我我具体记不清了，反正从天而降给他妈就压住。
压了一会儿之后吧。
可能一哆嗦这龙走了。
他妈就怀上他了。
所以他说他是龙种。
为了你看啊他平均出生嘛，得了天子位，然后。
即便是已经不是那个时代了，他感觉这个这个这个缺乏点。
支撑啊，他还在编这个这事，你看他妈就得配合然他妈在旁边吃，可能在那吃正吃饭呢，一听啊。
啊，是啊，大龙挺大的一个大龙压着笼挺沉的，哇得配合它一下啊。
对吧。
他妈的刘敖对吧？不是名字啊，就是刘老太的意思，对吧？刘老太，你看他家确实是平民出身，每个人都没名字，刘邦也没有名字嘛，刘邦叫刘继，对吧？在成事之前叫刘继，刘继就是刘老四的意思嘛。刘老四就是他家确实平民出身，没有名字都。
但关键是他忽略了一个问题啊，那些人上古时代的人为什么可以吹这个牛逼？
因为他爹确实不想了。
他回来咋吹都行了，但是你刘邦成事的时候，他爹还在呢。
他妈在哪配合他演出对吧？配合你演出那个啊对，是有条大龙压我。
然后他爸在那端着端一碗饭。
啊，是吧，他爸咋叫了？
后来他爸为了这个利益啊，也也也也配合了，说对我我去找你的嘛？我看见了，大楼压着你也不怨你，对吧？
把还配合，因为你要不配合，真的是吧？为了当皇帝啥事干不出来。
所以说你看啊这就是随便讲的小插曲，就是啥呢？
英雄啊。
确实有共同之处，刘邦当然一定程度也算英雄嘛。
千面英雄，但其实英雄千面英雄，但其实英雄只有一面，长得都一样，世界各地的英雄都一样，还有很多共通的东西，对吧？然后在英雄的旅程中。
必然就有。
鱼。
母亲的。
决裂与母亲的保护。
进行决裂，在于复权争夺世界的控制权。
当然，我们的小豆子在与复权争夺控制权的过程中被摧毁了，彻底的失败。
这就是用英雄这个关键词来解读。
这场戏大家记住。
千名英雄看美。
然后。
还可以有一个关键词，比千面英雄更通俗一点。
旅程。
下就去。
旅程旅程这个理论去，因为英雄必必定要踏上征程嘛。
用旅程这个理论去解读这场戏。
这场戏是什么？在旅程中是什么呢？
是。
受到了导师的召唤。
然后。
也经历了来自伙伴对他的试炼。
召唤试炼这几个关键词在旅程当中，我们说有导师的召唤。
谁让他说这段话，师傅让他背，我本是女娇娥，又不是男儿郎。
这是师傅对他的召唤导来自导师的召唤。在这个旅程这个概念啊。
来自于一本书叫作家之旅，大家可以去研究一下作家之旅。
作者叫。
沃格勒。
我个脸名字他妈的。
沃格勒啊就这个作家他呢是坎贝尔的学生。
他也是坎贝尔的这个这个学生，非常推崇千面英雄的理论。然后呢，他千面英雄，我说了是神话比较写的神话比较学的书。他基于这本书写了一个关于创作。
关于写作。
相当于。
我读千面英雄对写作的。
这个读后感他写了这么一本书，叫作家之旅。它里面的关键词就是旅程，你用旅程的。
理念去看待这场戏。那么这个小豆子在。
自己的旅程中，显然在这里经历的是导师对他的召唤。因为。
沃格勒在个英雄的旅程里面是有一个。
完整的一个。
路径的。
他是。
旅程啊还有完整的完整的一个路径。在这里，他经历的是导师的召唤以及拒绝召唤。我们说导师召唤你之后，你必然要拒绝的。
必然要拒绝的。
在我们的。
剧本里面剧本创作里面，我们管这叫争执，记得吧？争执。
争执在第一次选择之前有争执，他在这里呢叫导师对你的召唤以及你对召唤的拒绝。然后经历试炼是与伙伴在一起的。
导师让你背，你不背，你背错，然后最后谁帮助你成长，谁帮助你失业。
跨过第一道坎，我们说跨过第一道门槛，打开自己的第一个域。
第一个行为的欲。
是来自于伙伴。
也就是他的诗歌来自对你的试炼。
对你的锤炼。
这就是从旅程的角度，哎，也能很凡尔赛的解读一下这场戏。你可以说啊，这里是小豆子，在他的。
旅程中经历了导师的召唤，但是他拒绝了召唤。
因此，得到了伙伴对于他的试炼，帮助他打开了新的预知，不一定是成长，也有可能是对吧？
疯魔了嘛。
关于小豆子的。
小豆子一步一步的发展，他到底是成为英雄了，还是成为反英雄了？其实我们不需要去定性。
因为这个影片本身也没有定性说小豆子到底是变得更棒了。因为生活啊现实中啊不一定非得是说什么是往上走往下走，它只不过是在往前走。
所以戏里面对小豆子最后成为承蝶一的定性，也只不过是说他不疯魔不成活。
好吧。
所以在小豆子的旅程中，他在这里经受了召唤，经受了试炼。从这个角度我们也可以。
解住上析。
然后在这场戏之后，他越过了第一道边界，真正成为了。
成叠真正成为了女角额。
女交额。
旅程第二个关键词。
啊，吕成啊。
第三个关键词。
如果你想要很凡尔赛的解读一场戏，第三个关键词。
反而更常用，就往啥上靠呢？信。
就不管啥往性上解读。
或者是往。
童年这个大家一下就明白了，往性上解读，往童年上解读。
这不就是弗洛伊德嘛？
弗洛伊德嘛。
往性上解读，这场戏也可以瞬间逼格很高。
那这场戏咋往信上解读呢？
师兄怎么帮助他成长的？
用烟袋锅子。
用烟袋锅子捣烂了他的嘴。
在捣烂他的嘴之前。
他非说自己是男儿老。
他每次都说我我本是男儿了。
捣烂了之后。
他终于说出了那句。
我本是女娇娥。
所以那个烟袋锅子。
代表啥？
这个行为代表啥？
从性上解读，大家心里。
也基本有数了。
所以说这场戏你可以理解为是对小豆子的一场。
精神阉割。
彻底。
严格了他。
精神。
从弗洛伊德的角度讲啊。
嘴巴。
也是。
不能说是性器官吧，就是人是有口预期的。
就人是有口谕的，因为小时候有一个口欲期，就是你小时候啊你获得满足，来自于嘴。
基本上是从吃奶开始的对吧？你吃奶开始接触这种满足嘛，是从嘴上开始的。所以说你看啊这不就是童年嘛？幸与童年嘛，这就是弗洛伊德爱讲的。
关键词，那哎你小时候吃奶这个记忆，因为人跟动物不一样啊。
人跟动物不一样，因为人啊这些记忆残留啊，因为大脑很发达。弗洛伊德的理论是有一定的基础的啊，就是你小时候的一些行为会影响你以后确实是会影响。那你看人小时候吃奶，因为曾经用嘴获得过很多满足。所以即便是长大了以后。
你拥有了真正的性性器官了。但是你在你的性行为中，嘴始终还是发挥着重要的作用。
嘴还是。
很很大程度的参与在你的。
性行为里边。
这是个动物就不存在这种情况，对吧？你看这驴马狗，他们就很就是。
该使啥使啥呗，对吧？你老使嘴干什么？
但是人呢因为口语。
有口遇，有口预期。
在你的童年里，所以残留在你的脑海里，你情不自禁的就上嘴了。好吧，所以说你看啊，那既然嘴有口语，嘴是这个也算是一定程度上。
性器官的代表，因为当时小豆子还还没成年嘛，还是小孩嘛。
那么诗歌用烟袋锅子捣烂了他的嘴，实际上就是对他的一次阉割。
一次严格。
所以。
如果你不知道一场戏怎么凡尔赛的时候，往性往童年上。
去聊一聊。
也可以瞬间。
干得对方一脸懵逼。
是吧因为他也是有基础的，它是弗洛伊德的理论。
当然了。
这种理论还有很多，比如说还有些什么关键词啊，比如说还可以说是人格面具。
人格面具，这是卡尔荣格的理论。荣格。
你就说哎，这是这是显然是小豆子撕裂了自己的人格面具嘛。
彻底走进了，因为人人呐。
荣格讲人都是2元的。
你男女2月。
直弯2元。
好坏2元。
好人坏人2元，英雄狗熊2元。
就是人都是2元的。
你身体里面都有。
只不过是一方压制了另一方，有这种理论吗？有这种理论就是一方压制了另一方。
不是有个理论说。
就是关于嗯。
男人是直的还是弯的，有个理论嘛。
说只要给你足够的时间是吧？每个人都是玩的。
比如说把你跟把你跟一个大帅哥。
扔在一个荒岛下。
永远也出不来了。
你多久会变弯嘛？每个人都有个时间。当然有的人可能是100年、300年钢铁之胆，对吧？那可能活不到那一天，但是每个人都有个时间。
开个玩笑啊，就是说从荣哥的理论，他认为都是二元的。你有一个面具，然后下面还有一个你。
2元。
因为荣格的思想有一个很重要的理念，就是关于。
潜意识嘛？它叫集体潜意识，就他认为这是共性的集体潜意识。
你。
小豆子。
走进了自己的。
潜意识里面。
他走进了人格面具的另一面。
阴暗面呃也不能叫阴暗面。
就是另外一面阴暗面不是贬义词啊，因为一面在外面晒太阳，另外一面它必然就是阴暗的嘛，但不是贬义的阴暗啊，小豆子走进了自己人格面具的阴暗面。
在这场戏之后。
走进了女交鹅的世界。
走进了你交友的世界。
因为。
男儿郎女脚鹅。
2元。
一个在外一个在内。那另外一个。
出来的话，另外就隐藏。
第一个。
从人格面具，从集体潜意识角度也可以解读这场戏，也可以我还甩不着硬词，这是荣格的。
还有啥？
还有那个还有一个关键词，我们可以也可以从认同的角度，这显然是一场自我认同的危机嘛。就这场戏啊你可以理解为自我认同的一场危机。
自我认同的危机嘛，他到底是男人了还是女交额，这显然是一种自我认同的危机嘛？这个是美国心理学家埃里克森的的的的理论。他喜欢用的词儿。而且他说，每个人在寻找自我，寻找真实自我的过程中，一定是伴随着黑暗和恐惧的。
所以把这场戏理解为小豆子自我认同的一场危机，一场探索，伴随着黑暗和恐惧。
也是可以的对吧？
这就是不同的关键词。但是我讲了这么多，同学们有没有发现一个问题啊？
其实说的还都是这场戏。
这场戏好不好？确实好确实牛逼。但是你觉得作者在写这场戏的时候有没有想这么多？
他不可能的呀。
不可能的呀。
他没有想这么多，他就是想写。
小豆子。
不听货，对吧？师傅呢整不了师哥推了他一把。
他就是这么简单的想，然后哎烟袋锅子孔他嘴，哎，觉得这场戏哎视觉上啊或者是从合理性上啊很有冲击力。然后他就这么写了。但是呢我们可以从各种角度去解读。
我们这样解读对不对呢？
也对也没错。
也没错。
所以说啊其实。
很多事情都是这样。
真理只有一个。
只不过每个人从不同的角度去理解去阐述真理就是这场戏好戏，每个人可以从每个人的角度去阐述去理解。
我只是提供这些思路，让大家去应对。
凡尔赛的场景咱别吃亏了。
对吧跟人家干起来时候，你别吃亏，我不想让我的学生实战派的学生，因为过于实战就吃亏了，那是不可以的对吧？
但是我们同学们心里要装的这个事儿，真理只有一个。
从不同的角度去解读而已。
不用太较劲儿，好吧，所以这堂课呢也就是给大家提供点思路。
大家听一听乐一乐就可以了。好吧，反正加出来的课，那就这样吧，下课。
嗯。